I'm sorry. Sorry.
And you were so much more handsome at the
time.
Well played. Well played.
See what you did. But at the same time, like
I said, and me, you know, I'm 56 years old.
Damn. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. Because it was a thought.
No, no, seriously, it was a thought.
It was a thought. And I blurted it out.
I didn't mean it that way.
I'm fine. Okay. But just understand.
I didn't mean it the way it came out.
We'll take a poll on how you meant it with
people here later after the show is over.
But I can sit up here and honestly say,
buddy, that that was from a place of love.
Got it. Damn, That was like, Damn.
You didn't. If we could play it back right
now, play it back.
These are two different damns.
Play it back in slow motion. There wasn't
nothing I said.
I said there was no like, wow.
I said, damn.
No, you said the word damn.
Do you want me to tell you how you said it?
I know how I said it. Do you want me to say
it back to you?
How I think you said it. Go ahead.
Damn, not. Not true, fam not true, fam.
I said, Kevin.
I said, damn it.
Each time you said it. Now it's gotten
quieter and quieter.
I could barely hear you that last time when
you said it.
Well, that means that you can barely hear
the truth.
So who has the problem here?
What's the problem? Maybe 56 is catching up.
I hope we do work again, Will, because I
don't know how much time you got left.
And I would you know, I would love for us to
f***ing do something before it's too late,
man.
I'm here. Yeah.
For now. It's not.
That's what I'm saying. We got to get it
done.
Well, all right. Let's hurry up and do it
then.
I guess. We have to. Is there something you
know about me that I don't know?
Like medical health, history wise?
I can't stay in it. See?
See, that was my attempt to stay in it.
There's things out there that I haven't done.
There's genres that I haven't worked in yet
that might include some song that might
include some choreography.
Nice. It might include.
But who would do it? There's.
What do you mean in what way?
You say it would include song and
choreography.
So if you wouldn't be in that, of course.
So who would do it?
Why do you say it like that, though?
What do you mean? You can't
dance? As if. As if I can't dance.
What are you talking about?
You can't dance or boogie oogie oogie.
What are you talking.
What is that? What is Boogie Oogie oogie?
Are you 78? What is that?
I'll show you later.
The f*** just happened.
I don't know who I turn into you.
I'll boogie oogie. Boogie.
What the f*** are you talking about?
Why you got to say it like that?
Like it ain't got to be you.
You know, Not always, but.
I've been in the business.
You trying to age me up, huh?
You trying to Don Cheadle me right now?
I knew this was going to. I promise I'm not.
Going to Don Cheadle. You.
I've been in the business since I was 18, 32
years.
Oh, the feeling was so priceless was Don's
face.
Give me. Give me. He's got a great poker
And you caught him off guard.
How long have you been ready for?
I'm not going to f*** with you.
No, no, it's okay. I'm 32 years.
I take pride in that.
32 years. 32 Started in music business.
And then my first movie I made when I was 21,
22.
And this has been like the I'm f***ing I'm
pushing 60 years old.
I know that. Thank God.
Sorry. Sorry. Good God.
I just had.
That was f***ed up what you did to Don
Cheadle, by the way.
No, you're pushing 60.
Absolutely. I mean, look.
But, you know, it's the it's the elephant in
the room regardless.
And, you know, I like that you let the
elephant in the room just stay in the room.
But, you know, the reality is what like I
mean, I.
Feel like I'm in a business where I can be as
creative as I like for as long as I would
like. But being the front man, getting on
the mic and all that s***, it's I don't know.
I think, you know, I was funny about doing
the Super Bowl because I'm at this age, but I
felt like because we're in LA and the Rams
are here and.
I like that. You're mindful of that though,
because some people are lost in it and you
don't like you know, you don't want to
accept the fact that, Hey, man, look, Tom's.
Yeah, times change.
This thing that we do, especially hip hop, is
a young man's game.
Yeah, absolutely.
How long can I get away with this?
I mean, I can get away with producing young
artists, and, you know, I can.
My 90th birthday, I can blow out 90 candles
and produce a young artist.
That's at 22. I can.
We don't want to see you back, Randy.
With the with the bandana.
You're not going.
To see me, though. No, I'm I'm just in the
studio playing and doing my thing, but.
With the Dickies on it.
No, no, you won't see that.
I promise you. You won't see that.
Like, I didn't even know who you were until I
saw the movie.
And I was like, Oh, my God, this guy is
amazing.
And you were so much more handsome at the
time, remember?
Yeah. And younger.
Yeah. Fresher.
Yeah. But you're doing great.
No. Yeah.
Yeah. No, yeah, absolutely.
It was weird. I think we kind of.
I think it took like, I thought, I thought
you were going, like, in the space of a
compliment. And then they say, boom, it just
went down.
It was a.
Compliment.
Yeah, well, until you said was like.
That was when I was younger. I still felt.
Like, Well, I'm not lying.
It's a fact. You were younger 20 years ago.
Yes.
Well, I mean, it depends on how you look at
me.
Well.
I'm 50 now.
I was, like, fresh at that time.
Now I'm like, Sophie, you look great.
Yeah, I'm serious, but I'm 50.
You look great.
Inside. I'm 50.
Inside, you.
Know, Actually, no, inside.
I feel like I'm younger, but.
Everything.
What is that? What? Does that happen?
No, Stop it.
No.
Yeah. It's like everything is starting to
like.
No, you know, it's like.
You look phenomenal.
Phenomenal. Yes.
What is it? That's great.
Here. Oh, motherf*****.
Oh, God damn it.
Is it bad, guys?
Guys. Is it bad? Get up.
Jesus. Low blow.
That was a low blow. Well played.
Well played.
You see what she did? Anybody see what she
did there?
Try to make it look like she was helping me.
When, in fact, she just put me down, didn't
she?
Hurt my goddamn confidence.
For your 60th birthday, was there a big
like.
I'm not 60 yet, kid.
When is it?
I just turned 58.
Just turned 58. So it's.
Well, basically, you're 60.
Yeah. All right. We can fight it here.
You're right here.
All right. I'm knocking on 60 doors.
You're knocking on 60 doors? Yeah.
A big extravaganza.
A big event. How old are you now, Bill?
67. 67 is still.
Still operating.
Still a machine and still, like, churning,
you know?
This country is very unhealthy.
So they have this idea that you're decrepit
if you're 50, which I always thought, too,
because when I was 50.
What?
Until you got 50?
No, no, I'm still not decrepit.
That's what I'm saying is like when I was
younger, because of the way people act and I
would see the way they act and the way they
regard.
And it's very ageist country.
I would have thought, Oh, when you hit this
age, you'll just be very different.
And the truth is, there's almost nothing
different about my
life. With the transition from music to
acting, right?
And of course, we're talking about, you
know, this is 30 something years ago, right?
I'm not going to damn you. But we're talking
about a very long time ago, you know, and
this is not a you're not old, but you're.
Going to go back to it.
I'm just saying. But f***.
Right. It's a long time ago at this point in
time, man.
The only thing I'll be able to go to is the
short jokes.
Come on. I'm trying to stay off of that at
this time, though.
Tom Holland want to work with you.
You make us look tall.
I couldn't have played that ten years ago.
No, you're good. You know what I mean?
Like, I wasn't that guy.
You're. I've seen you.
I'm 56.
I've seen you. Now, don't give me that Don
Cheadle.
I almost did it. I almost.
Yeah, I almost did it just now.
Why do you do that to Don Cheadle?
I'm the greatest actors of our time.
Almost. You cut me off as I was about to.
Uncomfortable. I was right.
It was right here. He's such a cool guy.
I grabbed the chair because I was going to
do it with such aggression that it was going
to pull me up and I was going to have
myself.
Damn. Yeah. Yeah.
It's like, what the f***?
You're 50, Don Cheadle.
You're 56 now, like you said.
Okay. You wouldn't have been in position to
do what you did.
But six, man. But 56 is only
young when you die
at 56.